straight ahead on law and crime daily
attorneys for laurie valodebow won her
trial moved out of the same county
where the bodies of her two murdered
children were buried the request filed
as the doomsday mom stands incompetent
to proceed
bernie spears mother petitioned for her
right to hire her own attorney the legal
battles in the pop star's
conservatorship
as some announced they're stepping down
while others say not so fast
kyle rindhaus's attorneys signal more
possible defense strategies
wanting to show that one of the deceased
victims was a sex offender
six months since the deadly insurrection
at the nation's capital
the newly released videos the fbi is
asking for your help to identify
suspects
and why the so-called q anon shaman
won't be getting out of jail
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
we begin with the so-called doomsday mom
lori valodebel
her attorney is filing a series of
pre-trial emotions while she is
receiving mental health treatment
lori valo day bell's attorney is asking
to move her trial out of fremont county
idaho defense attorney mark means says a
fair and impartial jury
could not be found there in idaho lori
is charged with the murders of her two
children
seven-year-old j.j valo and 16-year-old
tylie ryan
along with conspiring to commit the
murder of tammy dabell
the wife of her fifth husband chad
daybel lori's case is currently on hold
she was deemed incompetent to stand
trial and was transferred to a mental
health facility
in the meantime attorney mark means is
filing a reservation of rights and
defenses
notifying the court laurie will not
waive her right to defend herself
and in a third motion means is asking
the court to show
cause for why two of the state's
witnesses should not be held in contempt
for not turning over evidence to him
means claims chad dabel's sister-in-law
heather
along with one of the couple's friends
melanie gibb refused to give him
communication records
lori is also facing charges in arizona
for conspiring to commit the murder of
her fourth husband
charles valo charles vallo's brother
told east idaho news
that for lori and chad the death penalty
would be the easy way out
you know i'll tell you something
she ain't crazy they knew exactly what
she was doing
and that's the truth if and when
she is found guilty of her charges
what's that for conspiracies uh death
penalty
i'm not i'd rather see her right in
prison for the rest of her life
and enjoy that kind of lifestyle while
the charges against laurie are eligible
for the death penalty
prosecutors have not yet said if they'll
seek it if she's convicted
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney julie rondelman and terry
austin
julie with lori vallo incompetent to
stan trial
why would a lawyer serve all of these
motions
so i the simple answer is that she's not
going to always be incompetent uh the
goal is right now is to give her
rehabilitation so that she'll have an
opportunity to be able to be tried
before a court of law and so
the defense is doing what he should be
doing is he's getting ahead of things
he's
making sure that all his ducks are in a
row because eventually when she
is found company doesn't want to be in a
position where the judge says
you know too little too late so he's
getting it done now because eventually
it will be needed in the future
make sense like you said get your ducks
in a row terry the death penalty wasn't
on the table when valo was arrested but
since then
a number of murder charges and even
conspiracy charges to commit murder have
been out added
so could that change you know what brian
anything is possible unless we already
have a confirmed
plea deal that has been approved by the
judge and we don't have that
if any case calls for the death penalty
it is this case
i don't think death is the easy way out
to tell you the truth it's a severe
punishment
obviously we have multiple murders we
have murders of
children involved so i definitely think
that if the prosecution were to decide
to bring the death penalty against
either
lori or chad they would absolutely be
right to do so
right we'll see how that plan plays out
sorry for many states you have to
make them aware either the court or the
defense that you're seeking the death
penalty of course we have not heard that
as of yet thank you both now to
california where attorneys are gearing
up for a big fight at the upcoming trial
for theranow's founder
elizabeth holmes homes is set to stand
trial beginning august 31st
for charges of wire fraud and conspiracy
to commit wire fraud
she's accused of defrauding investors of
millions and scamming doctors and
patients at her blood testing startup
a judge has ruled prosecutors can
present 13 documents between homes
and the high-profile law firm of
attorney david boyes the documents were
reportedly about home's attempt to sue
the wall street journal
julie can you break down attorney-client
privilege for us and why
it might not apply to these 13 documents
sure i mean attorney-client privilege is
basically that you have an opportunity
to speak to your attorney without the
risk of
anyone finding out what you have to say
and that is something imperative in
order for us to be able to go forward
with any of these cases whether they be
civil or criminal in this case
you know the judge's position is wait a
second this isn't
a attorney-client privilege she didn't
have a retainer agreement in writing
with this firm
she didn't pay this firm out of her own
fund she paid it out of
the corporate funds and so this is a
corporate privilege and so therefore
those 13 items are potentially
not falling into the attorney-client
privilege that she so hoped
um would be would be used in this case
yeah maybe the corporation is a client
but not
elizabeth holmes herself now terry do
you agree with the judge's decision
and do you think uh holmes could
potentially appeal the decision even
before the trial
yes brian i do agree with the decision
and she could appeal the decision that
would be what we call an
interlocutory decision where you're
having a decision made on a particular
issue
prior to the merits of the case you have
to have a couple of things you have to
make sure that
the issue has been conclusively
determined and that has been done here
it has to be an issue that's separate
from the actual merits of the case
and that has been done here and it has
to be unreviewable on
appeal after final judgment and i think
that exists here too so
basically the judge is making a decision
here based on
documents and discovery and i do think
she has the right to appeal that
interlocutory decision there
all right we'll see if she takes that
appeal and decides to go to a higher
court
before the trial starts because these
documents seem to be very damning
against her case
turning now to other top stories the
young woman who filmed the video of
george floyd's murder
on her cell phone now says her uncle was
killed by a police car
pursuing a carjacking suspect accused of
multiple robberies
darnell fraser posted on facebook saying
her uncle laniel lamont fraser
was struck by a minneapolis police squad
cruiser investigators say the officer
was chasing a suspect
when it collided with a vehicle at an
intersection minneapolis police has cost
my whole family
a big loss fraser wrote you took an
innocent life
trying to catch someone else still ahead
on law and crime daily
why one of the jurors in the robert
durst trial had to be excused
but first more twists and turns in the
britney spears conservatorship battle
why the pop star's mom is filing a new
request on her behalf
next
[Music]
welcome back britney spears's mom is
speaking out in court documents backing
her daughter's desire to take charge of
her personal life
this comes as her current legal team
resigns law and crimes anginate levy is
here with the latest developments
brian brittany spears's mother lynn
spears has filed documents with the
court
asking that the court allow her daughter
to choose her own lawyer or in the
alternative
lynn spears wants the judge to appoint
an attorney
of britney spears choosings
one by one people who are part of
britney spears's professional life
are stepping away her longtime manager
larry rudolph has stepped down
saying his services are no longer needed
since he's been told spears plans to
retire
now spears's court-appointed lawyer
samuel ingham has filed documents with
the court
stating he and a firm he retained to
help represent spears
will resign after the court appoints a
new lawyer for her
the wave of resignations comes after
spears spoke during a june 23 hearing
in which she said she wanted the
conservatorship to end
spears's father jamie has asked for a
hearing to investigate his daughter's
claims of abuse
saying he's been handling her estate not
her personal needs since 2019.
i think the judge has got little or no
choice but to have a hearing um
when you have the conservator asking for
a hearing and wanting an evidentiary
hearing and what is the judge to do
california attorney mark garrigus has
been following the story
spears's contentious relationship with
her father has been no secret
she's asked that her father be removed
from the conservatorship as recently as
last november
jamie spears suggested jodi montgomery
the woman in charge of spears's personal
care was to blame
but a spokesperson for montgomery's
lawyer tells law and crime
ms montgomery has no plans to step down
as miss spears is temporary conservator
of the person
miss spears as recently as yesterday has
asked miss montgomery to continue to
serve
now lynn spears says in those court
documents that her daughter is perfectly
capable of making her own decisions in
her personal life
the next date for that conservatorship
in court next court date that is
is next week brian thanks angenet now
julie brittany wants to be able to pick
her own lawyer and seems to suggest
that she doesn't agree with her court
appointed attorney what do you make of
the court reporter attorney
uh resigning so it seems like everyone
uh is resigning when it comes to the
britney spears saga and
and you know there's several reason
reasons that could be happening is one
is she's discharged them she doesn't
want to work with them
or two they don't want to work with her
it's possible that the communication has
been broken down to such an extent that
they don't think that they can represent
her properly
we obviously don't know the full detail
we do know that it's imperative
that an individual be represented by
someone that they trust
and are comfortable with and that seems
to be what britney spears
and her mother are asking for and so
that seems like something that they may
very well be entitled to
now julie i just want to highlight that
phrase because that is a very important
phrase when communication breaks down
between a client and a court appointed
attorney that's one of the few ways that
they can actually step aside and a court
will appoint another attorney
uh terry brittany's mother lynn spears
actually filed a motion requesting a
private attorney
with a list of demands what exactly is
she requesting
you know the very first thing she said
brian was i need the court to listen to
the wishes of my daughter and i think
that's very important
and the number one wish was the fact
that brittany wants to have her
own attorneys appointed as we already
heard from antoinette and that makes
complete sense
and one of the things that she also lin
mentioned in her court papers
was that she thought britney was very
courageous
during her june 23rd court appearance
where britney spoke out and defended
herself
and i think most importantly the one
thing that she has confirmed in these
papers
is that britney can take care of all of
her own affairs and she stands by her
daughter
and she thinks the conservatorship
should end so hopefully the court will
listen to her
yeah the desire to hire a private
attorney makes what julie said even
makes more sense i would agree
uh in terms of where the family wants to
go in terms of direction
hasn't there been some reporting
recently that suggested samuel ingram
was more loyal to the conservatorship
than to britney spears
yeah the new yorker magazine ronan
farrow wrote an article along with
another writer with the new yorker and
they talked about how there were people
who were suspicious that he was really
part of this conservatorship
system and that he was making a half a
million dollars a year or more the new
york times also reported that ingham may
have made as much as three million
dollars
throughout the course of this
conservatorship uh through britney
spears off of the conservatorship
in legal fees so that's quite a bit of
money over the last 13 years
absolutely thank you everyone for that
input now to texas where it was a rough
day
for a french bulldog puppy named mario
after two women stole him from a pet
store
it happened in the city of shenandoah
pentland store employees called police
and said the women walked out of the
store with a puppy and got into a car
with no license plates
officers found the car and pulled it
over the puppy snatchers were taken into
custody and mario was returned to the
store
safe and sound coming up on law and
crime daily the shocking location of
where cadaver dogs sniffed out
a missing boy plus looking back at the
riots at the capitol six months later
hundreds of defendants more than a dozen
guilty pleas what's next
in this unprecedented prosecution
[Music]
welcome back as we come to the six
anniversary of the capital riot
a judge is ordering one of the key
defendants to remain in jail
pending trial six months since the
deadly insurrection at the nation's
capital
535 people have been arrested and 13
have pled guilty the fbi says hundreds
of more investigations are still
ongoing and more serious charges are in
store on tuesday the fbi released 11 new
videos of suspects
assaulting federal officers seeking the
public's help in identifying them
but for one defendant whose identity has
long been known
a judge denied his request to be
released to an undisclosed secure
location
with his family jacob chansley better
known as the q anon shaman
is accused of storming the capital
carrying a flagpole with a spear as a
weapon
his attorney previously appeared on law
and crime daily saying his client was
duped by conspiracy theories
there is an alternate universe that
happens to exist in this world
and sometimes some people embrace it and
they move forward with it
and they have an issue my client has
happens to it doesn't take much to look
at my client and say you know what
maybe just maybe he doesn't fall within
the bell curve
of that which you and i would consider
normal
back to breakdown the q on shamans cases
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman
and co-host terry austin terry do you
agree with the judge in keeping the
shaman
in till trial or could there have been
another form of bail like an ankle
monitor
while he weighs trial i definitely think
that the charges were serious enough so
that he should remain in trial and you
have to think about whether or not he is
a threat
to society federal prosecutors actually
thought that
he was and that many of the writers were
because
they made specific threats to lawmakers
and so i think
if you keep that in mind that is not the
type of person
you want outside of court even if they
have a
monitor and they are being closely
watched so i think it was the right
decision here
it makes sense based on that fact
because with bail you first have to
consider are they going to come back to
court and then second are they a danger
to society based on that point it seems
like yes to both
julie was such a high profile defendant
do you think there is a plea deal
to be made here or should we all just
expect to trial
i don't know i think one of the big
problems that we have here is and it
seems obvious from even what the defense
attorney said is that there seems to be
a mental health component
a problem with regards to this defendant
when there's a mental health component
it makes it much more difficult
to plead guilty um because you have to
acknowledge your guilt and you have to
acknowledge intent
i mean look anything can happen i think
you know at this point the pro
the defense is standing you know pretty
firm um in regards to defending his
client
but again uh it it's still pretty early
on
um and at the end of the day it's not
unusual to see defendants plead guilty
particularly in these type of cases
absolutely we'll see how that plays out
i agree with you the mental health
aspect but also the video is pretty
damning and
no one's going to miss him on any of
those photos thank you both
when we come back attorneys for kyle
written house now pointing a finger
at one of the victims the legal
arguments of the defense for the accused
kenosha shooter
next
welcome back one of the jurors in the
robert durst trial has been dismissed as
testimony in the trial of the real
estate air has now resumed
robert durst is accused of murdering his
best friend susan berman in december
2000.
on wednesday the judge announced one of
the jurors in the months-long trial
must be excused due to medical reasons
bringing the total count of the jury
down to 18 members in court attorneys
are now reading transcripts from durst's
2003 trial
for the death of his neighbor morris
black durst was acquitted of murder
but testimony is allowed into this trial
because prosecutors are allowed to offer
evidence
ruled as relevant now to colorado for
the trial of mark redwine where one of
the witnesses says a cadaver dog smelled
human remains at the defendant's home
redwine is charged with second-degree
murder of his 13-year-old son
dylan redwine dylan's remains were found
less than a year after he disappeared
while on a court order visit to his
father the dog's handler says it
indicated multiple times
there could have been remains at the
first floor and near the garage of
redwine's house
the defense objected to this testimony
pointing out the dog could have signaled
false positives
and the scene could have been
contaminated tune into the law and crime
network for capital gavel coverage
and in wisconsin attorneys for kyle
renton house want to be able to show a
jury
that one of the victims was a registered
sex offender rinhaus is charged with the
murder of joseph rosenbaum
and anthony humber as well as attempted
murder of a third man
joseph rosenbaum was convicted in
arizona for having sex with a minor in
2002
and was prohibited from possessing
firearms attorneys for rent house say
rosenbaum started the fight with
rittenhouse
trying to take his assault style rifle
reinhaus traveled from illinois to
kenosha wisconsin
during protests over the police shooting
of jacob blake reinhaus maintains he
fired in self-defense
he's scheduled to go to trial on
november 1st prosecutors are now asking
to allow him to trial
a video from july 2020 which they say
shows rin house striking a teenage girl
in the back his defense says the
incident is irrelevant to his charges
prosecutors also want to argue that
reign house is affiliated with the
far-right extremist group
proud boys photos taken at a bar show
rittenhouse making a hand gesture with
people
in the group defense attorneys say race
wasn't a factor in the shooting
rainhouse is due back in court in
september
all right so we have two prior incidents
one by the victim and one by kyle
rittenhouse that
either side probably wants in for their
own reasons julie for
rosenbaum's sex registration that was
almost two decades ago
could that come in at trial i i highly
doubt it i mean
the argument from the defense is that it
should come in in order to show that
he wasn't allowed to carry guns and he
wanted to get
written house's gun which makes no sense
because after all these years if he
wanted to get a gun he would have found
a better way to get the gun other than
getting it from written house i think
the second issue is that
rittenhouse there's no evidence he knew
this guy was a sex offender
which would be in regards to the whole
self-defense matter and so i think this
is really just a ploy on the part of the
defense
to get in evidence in front of a jury
that would somehow
malign and make the victim in this case
look worse than they they are and so i
don't think it's going to come in i
can't imagine a judge letting it in
absolutely i would agree with you there
but maybe it's also they're trying to
get out into the media
so maybe the pre-jury pool can hear it
as well we'll see how that plays out
terry rinn house striking a teenage girl
is horrible
but it's a little different than
shooting someone on the streets
so could that come in you know brian it
is
horrible but it's extremely different
and i think for the reasons that we just
heard julie articulate
it shouldn't come in i mean under rule
404 b
we know that a prior bad act should not
come in unless it's showing intent
or some type of scheme and here hitting
a teenage girl has absolutely nothing to
do with the charges
that we have against written house and
so it's going to be
more prejudicial than it will be
probative and i definitely don't think a
judge is going to allow it
yeah i would agree with you both i think
that this is
both sides attempting to try to carve
out or to create a narrative to help
either side
but i think at the end of the day
neither of them are coming in
because they're not relevant and i think
you brought up that 404 b
argument perfectly uh terry in terms of
why
it wouldn't come in terry what about the
proud boys aspect of this although could
that come in
you know that could come in because i
think it has something to do with motive
and or intent but the teenage girls
incident shouldn't come in i mean if you
think about weinstein and you think
about
bill cosby and those types of cases when
other incidents came in
it was relevant this is not all right
we'll see how it plays out thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you